ええええええ
[音楽]
明けましておめでとうございます
へいへい
今日は我が家社長です
という気で40万円の空を買ったんですけども
何か使える場所がないんですよ餌がいるからなんとか家の中でやってみるものの全力で
叩けなくて近所迷惑で叩けないんでどこだったが叩けるかなと思ってな警察の人に連絡
したり色々したんですけどもありがんだったらワンちゃん ok って感じでした周り
の人に
迷惑がかからなければいいって感じだったのでご覧ください6人ですちなみに厚谷ロー
実にも曲はとりましたここにあるイチゴ農園にも許可はとりました誰には迷惑をかけず
に海だったらやってよって完全のことを聞いたんで表やりたいのは
とランドとの限界でどこまで届くのか試したいと思いますいろんな音出るので使ってき
たんですけどたぶんこれが一番音が出る響きが持つ
人が違いすぎて何メートル先までブランドをとって聞こえるのがちょっと検証していき
たいと思いますどうするのゲー好きだってますね
いや速い車ってな目で見しなきゃどうぞ日々
いいか
奴がいるここに500m の日も待って見える500m
これなくガチでヤバいよすぎで100メートル台で報告が100名の先で聴こえるか
聴こえたらさらに100メートルの張って200m 根津メートル聞こえでは300m
って感じで何年先まで聞こえるか減っ称していきたいとおもいます
一杯ッ容疑でこの先ずっと行きたいんで
ドナーここでに持っています
あって思いこれここが0メートルでそういうここから100年と手を組めていき
ましょう
いってらっさーいビッパタックこれ
ファー
はいオッケーみたいですこれ見えるかなここからはず待っての
ここでっ
では早速100m いきましょう
[音楽]
います
家族で行きが済んだような対処
ええええええ
ないわけで100あさせる3超えましたでこのまま朝に200m までいきます
[音楽]
敗2分けで200m があちらです
東伊那関係加藤ないブロックリスライトを得だと思ったらちょっと見てみます
ギリギリ見えるぐらい
ワレサが必須いい
[音楽]
ああ
やばいん
ああああああ
潤これから気づいたぞなんかカメラとかもとないどうせてオールだけ走る量を冒して前
に100m でこの犬ですよ
では200 get できます
[音楽]
聞こえるんだすごいすごいじゃあまだはや
300名とできます
[音楽]
300m ねーいやもう遠いぞまで混ぜとエゾお金がすごいって居るの
移動距離だよねなんとカメラで見ることが出来ますこれこれでさああなんかもやもやし
てるな
八橋
これじゃ遠くなるだめちゃくちゃ馳せるなどだ
それさえ増えていきます
tan
生まれ
もう1回いきます
dare
見えない見えない聞こえてるかどうかが分からないこそスケビ聞こえた
ああ
てもう1回やっていて気まぁちょっと本気で戦っ
ni
tan
駅超えれ
そう聞こえちまったかやだないってきまーす
ああああああああ
なあもベッドラットがいいですけど移動距離が長すぎでは
藩400メートル地点でも一応見えばたダメとした通りです1回ている
surf 4聞いてほしいですよません
なお逆に聞いてみたいんだあー概要沿革
あの1回記事見でははいというわけでちょっとね僕も完全データもあるんで1回お役目
と聞いてみましょういやどらーんでもないんなら波の音もあるからねそこらへんも影響
してる気がするんですよ
サイズでも来い
[音楽]
前節じゃないですか皆さんお年気配準備ができたみたいでございます
さあ
話に聞こえるのでしょうか宜しくお願いします
はああんっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
d っっ
麻生
[音楽]
yeah
teame
me
re だった